um being joined by uh at Middleton
British war hero former star of uh SAS
on channel it was way better when you
were doing it by the way
um I agree we got you on to defend our
country against the American uh media
that we're going to be doing in a moment
what is your view about this uniform
issue
with Harry because obviously just to be
clear if you are a veteran and you're
not a serving member of the Armed Forces
you don't traditionally wear a uniform
right it's only serving members of the
military but the Royals obviously have
honorary positions and as such that's
why they're allowed to work Edward quit
the Marines but he gets to wear one
because he's and so on the problem it
seemed here was they made an exception
for Andrew to where he is at one of the
events and I felt you couldn't possibly
do that and not let Harry do the same
well Andrew is controversial you know I
don't really want to get into that
debate because we all know you know our
feelings and faults on that but Harry
have he served you know he was he was
one of the lads you know he was heavily
connected to the Special Forces he
actually presented with my barium belts
when I got bad yeah so I got badge went
to pool and himself and uh Prince were
Prince Harry and Prince William were
there and they presented with librarian
Bell and he was known to be one of the
lads and he served he's been out to
Afghanistan he serves so rightly so he
should be allowed to wear his uniform
have no problems that no matter what you
think about him you know he deserves I
don't think you can take away you cannot
begrudge him full respect his military
service he did two tools of Afghanistan
and I would never begrudge in that at
all
um I've got other issues with him but
it's nothing to do with his military
service which which was beyond reproach
um stay with me out because we've got to
get into this big debate that's raging
over across the pond here of course
we've been in National morning the cue
to see the body of the late Queen is 4.9
miles long stretching from Westminster
all to well beyond tower bridge if you
join the line now it'll take eight hours
to reach the front and of course is that
pouring of patriotic further it's not
unexpected here in Britain neither the
side of the royal guards marching beside
a coffee date by the crown jewels but it
should top of velvet cushion this is
what we do but does a pump and pageantry
burn is Britain's image as a nation of
history and finesse or as some people
across a pond in America think have we
all gone slightly mad is it just Pomp
and pageantry hysteria more political
commentator and columnist Michael
Luciano Angelus Norther and Coulter join
me from America and I'm obviously got
the star well as he was the he's the
former star but he was to mean the star
of SAS who dares wins well it was a show
worth watching I do the Australian show
now so there we go yes and it's
excellent because you're on and all
right Michael Luciano your Economist
over in America and you think we've all
lost our mind why
well it's the year 2022 and you all
still have a monarchy up there does not
have the kind of political clout that it
used to which in a way makes it even
weirder because it's they serve the
royal family serves no real actual
function and yet you just kind of keep
them around
um but so I would say like here in
America we've lost our minds even more
because I understand all of the coverage
of the Queen's death and the Ascension
of Charles I get that from a UK
perspective but we here in the United
States for some reason are also all in
on the coverage of the royal family well
I think it's I think I think it's it's
buyer's remorse for getting rid of
George III isn't it you know you wish
you'd never done that you've had a
series
you've had a lot of presidents some of
whom were great and some of whom were
complete turkeys and each time you get a
turkey you think totally totally maybe
we should have had had George III and
his bloodline and just carried on you
might have had King peers by now you
played your cards right
yeah no the whole reason we fought the
revolution is so we wouldn't have to
care about any of this stuff and yet
we're still caring about it and the
media is in total overdrive George
Washington is rolling over in his grave
in a way I guess look I can understand
why some Americans don't get the concept
of a monarchy what I find really
objectionable is what some American
academics have been saying so there's
this woman called uju Anya she's
actually an academic A Carnegie Mellon
she she teaches people this woman and
she tweeted this I heard the chief
monarch of A thieving raping genocidal
Empire is finally dying May her pain be
excruciating
this woman is an assistant professor
teaching people
another assistant professor in Rhode
Island tweeted she would dance on the
graves of every member of the royal
family especially hers about the queen
now Michael this to me crosses a line
and I would feel the same if anyone in
Britain said this about a president who
just died what is wrong with these
people
well you know some people just have had
different experiences with
the queen in the house of Windsor more
broadly going back to uh you know a few
centuries so I can't really speak to the
experiences that they have had in their
families and their ancestors have had
with the British Monarchy it is not
something I would have tweeted but I am
not going to pass judgment really you're
not going to pass judgment
you're not going to say that you condemn
that you don't you think it's you think
it's not worthy of condemnation that
somebody who teaches students in America
so she wishes the queen died of
excruciating pain
why wouldn't you condemn that yeah
it's not something I would have said
it's not great I don't know who that
person is I don't know what kind of
clout they have absolutely look it's
disgusting let's bring an Ann Coulter
and I think you like the Pomp and
pageantry of all the rules I mean some
of the Americans I know love it have
been as obsessing about all this as we
have what's your view
um well I'm not quite an obsessive but
uh in response to to Michael's points I
belong to an organization that
celebrates my many many ancestors to who
fought in the revolution that ended our
connection to the monarchy yet and still
I don't want a monarchy here very proud
of those of those ancestors of mine
um but this is a country that was did
live under the monarchy for 176 years I
love the monarchy not an obsessive
um it costs less for Britain to have the
monarchy than our National Endowment of
the Arts a National Endowment of the
humanities and I think you guys get a
lot more out of the monarchy I mean the
things they provide I don't think it
would be fun at all to be within the
royalty and I would recommend the
wonderful movie Roman Holiday which is a
great movie but really really makes that
point it's a lot of work they can't just
you know a poor Kate can can never wear
like a cut off jean skirt and a crop top
she can't dress up all preppy she has to
look elegant and beautiful at all times
and she does they all do they are so
elegant they are Role Models but I don't
even think it would be a fun life and
they do it and wow do the tourists like
it and I really enjoyed the um ceremony
that was going on this past weekend
um they kept cutting it away from it on
MSNBC to talk about you know the evil
history of colonialism I would also add
that the world was never so good as when
the Sun never sat on the British and
also the whole point the whole point
about this colonial issue let's bring it
out Middleton again the whole point
which a lot of Americans
who are being severely critical of this
queen don't seem to understand is she
took us out of this you know she was the
one that helped preside over bringing it
out of the Empire
decolonized a lot of the you know the
colonization she should be applauded for
this not castigated and blamed for the
sins of the past and that's what's
ingrained in our DNA that's what's
ingrained in our blood is where we are
today a lot of people want to go back a
couple of centuries and if that didn't
happen a couple of centuries a day we
wouldn't have the most open and
welcoming society as we have today you
know when you see this queen is our
grandmother's grandmother when you see
this academic you're teaching people
saying that she hopes the Queen's pain
was excruciating it's disgusting it's
absolutely disgusting and how she how
she ever thought that that was
acceptable there's nothing to say about
anybody about anybody let alone let
alone a 96 year old respectable uh young
lady like the queen
um how they get away is beyond me it's a
good job she's in America not in the UK
that's all I can say I just find it it's
it's a kind of repellent behavior and
she's of classic kind of woke academic
um let me bring back uh Michael here
Michael is there any part of of all this
which you can look at and wish you'd had
a bit of this in America
no
really
yeah really because I tell you why I
think what what we feel here
I'll have this chat with American
friends what we feel is that the
difference between your system and us we
obviously have a democratic system of
electing Prime Ministers and governments
in the same way that you do with with
presidents it's the same kind of thing
but the point of the monarchy if there
is such a a point and you could simplify
it would be that we have this continuity
above the Democratic process these are
unelected people yes it's hereditary but
they all understand what their job is
and their job is to act as kind of
comforter-in-chief to the country in in
bad times and they do it when they do it
well incredibly well this queen brought
huge comfort and Solace to this country
for 70 years and it's that part of it I
wonder whether even if you don't agree
with the idea of a monarchy do you not
sometimes wish that you had an America
this kind of non-partisan
non-controversial
finally over the top of the politicians
no I have an innate aversion to
hereditary aristocracy I think the Brits
as well as the Americans are hard-nosed
enough to be able to do without such a
an aristocracy and
you know frankly I regard the royal
family as I regard the Kardashians here
I mean what they are famous for being
famous they're very wealthy they
there are too many of them and I try to
avoid all mentions of them as much as
humanly possible I mean you did just as
a country you'll you'll immediate a
prior president was a TV star
reality TV story yes and I did not like
that at all right I did not like that at
all I mean your own Democrats are not
exactly thought proof is it
no it isn't but you know at least we
didn't elect the Kardashians I'm not
sure we did much better with Trump but
no uh no there's there's listen I mean
the best thing Charles could do is to
end the monarchy and he would be hands
down my favorite Monarch well that's
never going to happen and Coulter
um could I say I think the Kardashian
Point actually makes your point peers
um he's right I mean what that's our
royalty these utterly tacky disgusting
people you have a beautiful monarchy I
think you do make a very good point
about having a non-partisan head of the
country though I agree with I'm sorry Is
It Michael or Matt yeah Michael yeah
okay I agree with Michael that I don't
want a monarchy here but you know I
don't want bull fighting here I do want
it in Spain it's part of of what Britain
is
um and I think the colonies all owe
Britain for the wonderful things Britain
did to them bringing indoor plumbing and
railroads and educational and ending
hideous practices like throwing the
Widow on the funeral pyre getting the
resources out creating wealthy countries
out of just third world hell holes oh no
no the reparations should be going back
to Britain
you know what maybe you should come over
here and be a defender of Britain as
your new full-time job
I would like to could I also say
something I really like about
um King Charles that I don't think gets
mentioned enough
um yeah I mean okay global warming I
wish you dropped out there are enough
people cover covering global warming we
don't need him doing it but one of the
things I really really really strongly
support and especially having just
recently been in London again
um is his opposition to crap
architecture and wanting to preserve the
beautiful buildings and restore old
buildings London is such a beautiful
city I think it's the most beautiful
city in the world and you're going along
seeing these These Old gorgeous
buildings and there's some Modern
buildings that are cool and nice but
most of them are just pieces of crap
that get thrown up and he gets very
little credit for that he has excellent
taste
um I wish he would really hit that hard
as king and save London from ugly
architecture I never thought I'd say
these words but Britain salutes you Ann
Coulter thank you very much indeed for
your support
and and tribute to ankle to that and
just for Michael just to annoy him
he's loving it really like he's feeling
the stirring of his soul there he is
[Music]
and by the way I would stand as well for
the American national anthem because
when I'm in America and it's played
there because I believe you have a great
system too Michael I appreciate you
joining me and Coulter